we started something special here uh a
lot of belief in one another and what we
can do when we buy in and
and uh believe in each other and uh and
play together and we did that throughout
the whole season so yeah like i said i
love playing with these guys and i think
i think they feel the same way the
window is open for us
and that's the exciting thing who knows
what can happen i mean there's
it's a long year
but
this one will always be special because
it became fun again
ryan tannehill and aaron rodgers titans
quarterback and packers quarterback
respectively
i i don't know what look aaron rodgers
was going for there but i liked it i
liked it i just he just got into shore
after three months at sea they harpooned
a whale and uh he's in the bay area that
fits well he's in the bay area yes you
don't know he might have been out there
just catching some fish fresh fish and
now he played a little quarterback and
he's ready to go home
he looks angry i don't know that that's
still frame if you're watching well he
is a fair representation he sounded very
optimistic though chris oh yeah he said
we're gonna get one of these soon do you
think the packers have enough to to get
to the super bowl with this team as it's
currently constructed well i do i mean
he's disappointed of course i mean he
knows he's 36 years old you just you
don't know how many of the opportunities
he's gonna get so i'm sure that's going
through his mind a little bit but uh you
know he said it they are in the window
they're not far off i mean if you made
me pick you know both teams tennessee
pac you know tennessee titans green bay
packers which team is more likely to be
back in this position next year you know
hey i like tennessee's chances but i
think i would still go with green bay
and that argument i would and i just
think they're going to get a year better
within the lefleur offense like we
talked about they need another weapon or
two on the offensive side of the ball
they don't need much on defense they've
really just got to address their
interior d-line that was their biggest
issue on that side of the ball all year
long
uh they were exposed there and they got
exposed yesterday they had a game plan
to help that interior d line which made
them vulnerable on the edge so
i look at the packers and think they are
in pretty good shape now the nfc is
loaded but i still think this is a very
very good team that's uh not far off at
all
it'll be interesting to see what gm
brian gudekoons does this year and next
year from the standpoint of moving on
from guys they have because if you are
going to be very active in bringing in
new guys that means maybe some of the
guys who have been there don't fit in
the vision of the team going forward and
one of the things aaron rodgers was very
specific about as a basis for his
optimism for the future they brought in
players who are natural leaders and he
says for the first time in a while it's
fun again for him and if they get more
guys like the ones they brought in if
matt leflore who will be in his second
year's head coach continues to empower
guys to do their thing
things things could get interesting for
the packers i still don't know how they
were 13 and three i don't know that they
can duplicate that look at the chargers
last year they were 12-4 and they won a
lot of close games and then this year
they didn't i mean that's part of the
luck of the weekend week out grind and
sometimes you find yourself in a groove
where you're just winning these games
that maybe in any other year you would
lose so they still have to find a way to
win and rogers said this team isn't as
talented as others he's been on they
just found a way no guarantee next
year's team is going to find a way chris
no there is no guarantee plus you know
hey they they were
they were fortunate to play a a pretty
easy schedule this year you know for the
most part they got to play the nfc east
we know that was kind of a dumpster fire
they played the afc west and they got to
pike kansas city without patrick mahomes
you know the afc west was solid but
again nothing we're looking at going oh
wow that was some division there so i
think things fell into place that way uh
more times than not where they just got
yeah they found ways to win football
games will that happen again next year i
don't know but i do like their chances
with 12 at quarterback because he takes
care of the football and they got help
around him i think that's why he's
trying to say it's a fun year too you're
right i think they brought some
personality to the locker room that you
know juice things up a little bit and
the pressure's off of him a little bit
to where not every game was like whoa
aaron rodgers got a throw for 350 and
four touchdowns so they can't win a game
i mean that's how it's been for the last
eight or nine years so that pressure is
off and matt lafleur deserves that
credit that way now they just need to
find you know two three players to kind
of get them over the hump
real quick on the tennessee titans do
you think they are here to stay i i
think they are here to stay yes i i you
know they're a team you look at just
they got to sure some things up on the
defensive side of the ball a little
maybe another pass rusher something like
that but you know the big thing is with
them is you know early season you know
the last two years the last three years
it seems like they let too many games
slide away early in the season and derek
henry in the run game don't pick up till
november can they like you know win some
games they shouldn't win early in the
year to where they don't always have to
limp into the playoffs and put
themselves in such a tough spot but they
got a lot of pieces but they're in a
tough division we'll see where that goes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports